and no matter what comes of the fisa
investigation democrats are hoping that
special prosecutor Bob Muller will find
evidence of wrongdoing by the president
Republican strategist and Trump
confidant Roger stone joins us now to
share what he believes Muller is now
investigating
Roger joins us from Miami Roger it's
great to see you these leaks keep coming
out don't they of the Muller
investigation and I we're going to get
into a lot of it but some of it is now
seeming to focus on whether Donald Trump
knew about those WikiLeaks hacks or the
the the emails that WikiLeaks had of
John Podesta and the DNC and your name
keeps popping up as a potential
intermediary between I guess implied the
Trump campaign and Julian Assange
and I know you've been over this before
but this is all out there again today
Laura this is an attempt by the
handmaidens of the Democratic Party in
the mainstream media to re-inflate the
deflated Russian collusion delusion
let's be very clear the the truncated
doctored screenshot published by the
Atlantic magazine actually proves that I
had no advanced knowledge of the source
or content of the WikiLeaks disclosures
regarding Hillary Clinton and I never
claimed that I did Julian Assange
himself has said Roger stone merely
retweeted and followed what I was saying
and tweeted absolutely true and to be
absolutely clear I never discussed the
WikiLeaks disclosures regarding Hillary
or John Podesta which I also had no
advance knowledge of with candidate
Donald Trump before during or after the
election there's just literally nothing
there now all this material that was
released today had been turned over to
the House Intelligence Committee months
ago but this is an attempt to
essentially reinflates false narrative
but don't you also see a shift happening
Roger
they were set on the collusion narrative
and they've tried but it doesn't seem to
be really going anywhere
so now you you sense they're moving to a
compromise narrative namely that the
president reportedly must be compromised
in some way by Russia hence his soft
treatment of Russia and and I want to
play something for you from your dear
friend Jeffrey Toobin this morning on
CNN let's watch why
has Donald Trump been so favorable to
Vladimir Putin what is in it for him a
very clear possibility is business is
money is that he has business dealings
in Russia that he has wanted to
cultivate I just wrote a story in The
New Yorker about when he brought the
Miss Universe pageant to to Moscow in
2013 that led directly to the meeting in
Trump Tower of June in June of 2016 so
now Roger missed the Miss Universe
pageant is is brought into the equation
on the Muller investigation thoughts
there mean aside from the rank
speculation by Toobin well first of all
if we're so Pro pro-putin why is the
president providing offensive weapons to
the Ukrainians over the adamant
objection of the Russians look Donald
Trump didn't want to go to war over
Syria and Hillary Clinton was promising
the deep state an expansion of the proxy
war there if you look at Syria Assad
finances Hezbollah and Hamas propped up
by the Russians on the other side you
have Isis and a thousand other radical
groups we have no friends here Donald
Trump does not want to spend borrowed
American money or American lives going
to war with Russia over Syria a no-fly
zone as favored by Hillary Clinton and
John McCain would have been an
invitation for World War three so Donald
Trump was the peace candidate in the
last election
he has no illusions about Russia or the
corruption of the Russian system or the
fact that Putin is a bad guy but they
had thermonuclear weapons Laura
perhaps we should be talking to them and
and the idea that Trump is somehow
softer on the Russians then Obama was I
mean Obama's big push was December
20:16 okay we're gonna kick you know all
these Russian officials out of the
country but they were trying to do the
reset you know they you know you had the
sweetheart deal with Bill Clinton and
while hillary was Secretary of State we
did uranium one so I think the argument
is clear that if anyone was soft on
Russia it was Obama and why wasn't Trump
it was Obama who was soft while the
mainstream media is absolutely right
about the fact that there was a major
party candidate whose top aides were in
bed with the oligarchs around Vladimir
Putin
there was one candidate whose foundation
was taking millions of dollars from
Russian interests that would be Hillary
Rodham Clinton the Panama papers
published in January of 2016
exposed the Podesta brothers dealings
shady dealings in Russia the gas deal
the uranium deal the banking deal this
is all a matter of public records so she
was the candidate in bed with Putin
Donald Trump and by the way Roger I know
you'll love this story that's just
crossed Bonnie Axios Jeff sessions is
dining at a very high-profile restaurant
tonight with rod Rosenstein his deputy
and the Solicitor General NOLA Francisco
and this is being interpreted as a big
show of force DOJ in the face of the
Trump tweet this morning you thought the
rod Rosenstein approved the use of the
phony Russian dossier as the legal
rationale for surveillance of the
Republican candidate for president rod
Rosenstein should be terminated
immediately he has a conflict of
interest in the appointment of robert
muller who gave him his first job in
public service he's up to his neck in
uranium 1 as the US Attorney Rosenstein
must go first
then sadly Jeff Sessions should go next
all right Roger thanks so much